في غضون ذلك ، نحصل على صور
لموقع دفن جماعي مزعوم تم العثور عليه في
شمال شرق أوكرانيا يقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون
إنه يحتوي على ما لا يقل عن 440
قبرًا تم اكتشافه بالقرب من مدينة إيزيوم الآن
لم تؤكد سي إن إن من دفن
هناك أو كيف ماتوا لكن
الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي يشير
أصابع الاتهام في روسيا ، لمزيد من المعلومات حول كل ما
ينضم إلينا بن ويدمان من CNN على الهواء مباشرة من
كييف بن أعرف أه اكتشاف
موقع الدفن هذا لا يزال قصة متطورة
ولكن ما الذي يمكنك أن تخبرنا به
جيدًا أننا سمعنا في الأصل من
قائد شرطة  منطقة هاركيف
حيث يقع هذا القبر الجماعي
المزعوم الذي قال إنهم يعتقدون أن ما
لا يقل عن
440 جثة قد دفنت هناك الآن
مما نفهمه أه هناك
علامات على بعض القبور
تشير إلى أنها على سبيل المثال 17
تم وضع أشخاص من المشرحة
هناك وإلا فهي مجرد تقاطعات
بدون أسماء عليها ، لذا ليس من الواضح في
هذه المرحلة من هم هؤلاء الأشخاص
وكيف قتلوا  لكن إذا نظرتم على
سبيل المثال إلى الحالات السابقة حيث
تم الكشف عن مقابر جماعية خاصة
في بلدة بوتشا خارج
العاصمة كييف حيث وجد المحققون
458 جثة أه في مقبرة جماعية
أظهرت 419 منهم بحسب المحققين علامات
إعدام إما  تم تعذيبهم حتى الموت أو
ضربهم حتى الموت ، وأعتقد أن هذا
مؤشر على ربما ما سيتم
اكتشافه في هذه المنطقة الشاسعة التي تبلغ مساحتها 8000
ميل مربع حيث طرد الأوكرانيون الروس منها
في الأسبوعين الماضيين وتذكر
الروس ما زالوا يسيطرون على أجزاء كبيرة من
هذا البلد على سبيل المثال في مدينة
ماريوبول في الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي من
البلاد تحدث
المسؤولون المحليون الموالون للحكومة
في كييف عن عشرات
الآلاف من الناس أه يقتلون لذلك
نحن تفاصيل هذا القداس بالذات
القبر و easyium لا يزالان غير واضحين أه
نفهم أن المحققين يذهبون إلى
هناك في محاولة لكشف ما
حدث الصحفيون ذاهبون
لأخذهم أه اليوم ، لذا المزيد من
التفاصيل قادمة ولكن المعلومات الضئيلة التي
لدينا بالتأكيد تشير إلى أنها
مقبرة جماعية